amount of people that on hollywood
and have never been out there
is is the same number of people that
make fun of des moines iowa that have
never been there the mine's beautiful
tomorrow's beautiful place
des moines not in february
that's when i used to do all my college
gigs that's when i finally understood
slipknot i was like how the hell did
they get so damn angry out in this
beautiful
country out here and then i had a
college gig
in like february and all the crops were
cut down and it was overcast gray just
meeting this i felt like i was on the
moon
it was it was just the bleakness
and just the endless
the thing of it it was like uh yeah it
was like i was like wow man this must
get like
like what you would have to do
to to get the blood going out here man
it's just like i mean that is like
that's like you got to be tough oh yeah
to live out there